it seems to me like what happens and
this is just from my cursory glance of
being in I'm not in this field but of
surveying it is that people get into
this because they feel like it's
consequential it's a meaningful subject
they look into it then they're
confronted with misinformation and
disinformation they put a stake in the
ground saying I believe in this or I
don't believe in this they get then
pillow read from some side for taking
such a stand and then this happens
repeatedly to the point they say eff it
and f everything about this Fu for
excoriating me f myself for getting into
this it's not worth it
you nailed it ain't gonna lie there's no
way to there's no way to to rebut that I
think that that people get into this
because they're curious they want
answers some people have more time than
others
but
those that get into it and they see that
BS they give up we've seen it I spoke
about it previously a little bit but you
absolutely nailed it because those
people don't have time for the BS they
want the answers there's a lot of good
people out there that may even want to
believe they may even not know how to
research they may not know even how to
ask the right questions
um and I don't chastise those people
people at all they're curious they're
there they want to learn they want to
read they want to understand and that's
why I get passionate about the topic
because
there's so much there to think about and
so much real stuff to think about and to
explore and to learn from and to kind of
scratch our heads over and and and to
expand on we need more people to ask
those important questions or try and get
more answers
and that's why I get passionate because
when you see the BS slung people buy it
hook line and sinker and there's nothing
worse than realizing you were wrong to
believe it in the first place so the
normal reaction is see ya I'm done I'm
out and I you literally see those words
all the time on social media I'm out you
know like this is ridiculous I tried I
hung on I believed in this I thought we
were going to do that the empty promises
were here the anonymous sources were
saying this that and the other thing and
that's problematic we need those curious
minds that are here to learn that's what
this is all about because the
implications behind it are much more
than figuring out a program name or an
acronym or did this study UFOs or not
all of that stuff is just they're small
puzzle pieces that I care about because
I love history but this all sits on a
foundation that is much more important
and and and we question ourselves we
question who we are we literally can
question our place in the universe if
some of if any ounce of this is true if
any small percentage truly does connect
to an extraterrestrial whatever that to
me is is what's worth it and for people
to give up on that Curiosity that they
have uh because they were lied to
that's awful to me I hate it I really do
I think the the field if you want to
call it that has lost some great people
uh due to their bitterness their
frustration uh and their anger over what
they experienced and and in the cases
that I'm referring to firsthand
experiences and they felt duped and they
feel lied to and they feel that this is
a charade and so the two words I'm out
and they leave and I think that the
field itself has lost a lot of great
people because it deserves the attention
it deserves a scientific scrutiny and it
deserves the human mind to look at it it
really does I wouldn't be around down I
don't have time to waste my time on
something
um and yet I feel that it's worth it
because I think the root of it is
important and uh I think there's enough
evidence to to support that those that
want to should stick around and know
that those that are being caught in lies
or maybe out to be malicious or
whatever fill in the blank it's just
part of the territory I don't know why
that is it just is and we have to kind
of learn to differentiate that if they
say and I'll make it simplistic look I
researched this house and the house is
blue then fine prove to me that the
house is blue don't say trust me bro you
know and that's been kind of the ongoing
joke that a lot of this is now the whole
trust me bro you know I've got Anonymous
sources and I I pull my hair out with
the whole anonymous source thing I
really do because people base their
stories claims tweets blogs on all these
secret Anonymous sources and it's solely
based on that there's a room for
anonymous sources in journalism don't
get me wrong but when you solely base
your claims and in some cases or most
cases uh those claims are astronomical
uh it's just not going to cut it and it
doesn't do the field any good to make
these empty promises you know and uh and
that's again going back to what I was
saying a few minutes ago that's why I
get passionate that's why that's why I
get outspoken that's why I get myself in
trouble with some people and I've
learned to really try and just swallow
it and not go after people but yeah
sometimes uh you get angry because
people don't appreciate I think the
reality of of what this topic is uh and
the seriousness of it and when you don't
allow other facts to maybe change your
mind I have I've changed my mind a
thousand times over the years uh that's
okay we have to be okay with that
there's nothing set in stone yet
um but too many then fall victim to to
the uh my mind's made up don't bother me
with the facts mindset and then they
will go after the curious minds that I
were talking about they get chastised to
death and then they go you know what I'm
done and they leave
and it's a shame
let's talk about some specifics now what
are your views on the Wilson docks what
have you uncovered sorry Wilson memos
yeah it's a Hot Hot Hot Topic in the
last few years and it's one that I think
is fake
um and that's based on a couple of
different things when the story First
surfaced Look I I don't just
automatically dismiss but obviously I
was very skeptical there were a lot of
anonymous sources that fed information
to hear to there about the root of where
these documents came from that bothered
me from the get-go but I looked into it
anyway I was getting asked the question
a lot and so I I didn't mind looking
into it what I found was the majority of
the story uh Believers in this document
will disagree with me by the way but I'm
going to say it anyway hinged on a what
they called nro document or national
reconnaissance Office document that was
taken by I guess Stephen Greer and will
Miller and Edgar Mitchell to meet with
Admiral Wilson in The Pentagon and
essentially was giving them a mj12
keyword list Majestic stick magic all
these different keywords on this
document
well this document then set Wilson off
according to the story set Wilson off on
his journey to find these UFO related
programs ended up finding one or more
got denied access and he decides to to
come back and you know found Dr Eric
Davis met him in a dark Street on a I
mean I'm making a part of these but it's
like a movie you know meet some meet
some in Las Vegas they have their
conversation Eric Davis writes down
these notes and essentially the legend
is born
well the problem now going back to
that's an incredibly nutshelled version
of the story but the problem with the
start of the story is this nro document
the nro document is tied to a Dr Stephen
Greer and Stephen Greer has a
controversial past uh without going
through that part of it the document
itself in my opinion is easily is is an
easily proven fake uh I did a full video
breakdown of it there's a lot of reasons
why but the short of it is you have uh
quite a few errors within it you have
the wrong seal at the top it actually
has a U.S Air Force seal on it uh the
national reconnaissance office has its
own seal it's not part of the Air Force
people have tried to argue this uh look
no argument makes sense I I think that
people have realized it's a hoax after I
made this video The Believers in the
Wilson Davis documents have now uh said
the nro documents are relevant right so
we went from this is what set Wilson off
on the journey
I'm surprised that they didn't even
really fight me on the legitimacy of the
document they just kind of are now
removing it from the story and they're
saying well it doesn't really matter
what Greenwald says the document is fake
but who cares it's not it's not the glue
to the story well okay fine moving on
from that document the problem then is
the whole idea and concept that an
admiral a former J2 would violate a
security clearance come out and talk to
Dr Eric Davis in a car and allow him
either to take notes or have it you know
essentially
um being put out into the open I mean
those guys both have security clearances
Davis included so the likelihood of that
would be incredibly nil people fall back
on the notes uh saying Wilson stated if
it ever came out he would deny it so
Wilson has denied he's got on the record
with uh journalist out of Florida and he
denies the whole thing well the
Believers go aha the note said he would
deny it Ergo it's true I'm like okay you
guys gotta look at the anatomy of a hoax
here I mean you can clearly set up these
these types of fail safes uh to to
safeguard from that so Wilson uh says no
it didn't happen aha you have your aha
moment and that to me is just kind of
laughable but people really believe that
well Wilson said it so therefore he's
lying
um I I don't understand that and Eric
Davis has no comments he's never
commented on it there was talk in the
first UAP hearing about the Wilson Davis
notes and I just I Politico quoted me in
this I called it a face palm moment and
it was just like oh God like what of all
the history of UFOs of all the documents
that are available of everything that
you guys can can can throw in front of
Congress all of a sudden Wilson Davis
comes up and I call it a face palm
moment but then I started thinking about
it after the fact and Politico published
their piece and I stand by my quote but
now I'm like throw him in front of
everybody
put them under oath and ask him sorry I
thought I meant them but but throw them
in front of everybody and and put them
both under oath
and have them tell the story and if
Wilson still denies it then where do we
go from there uh and and just call it a
day but the problem for me is that's not
what we should focus on in my opinion
because I just don't think it's it's a
legitimate thing
um other people have and I want to make
sure I add this in because I'll get a
lot of hate mail uh from your fans that
that may support this document but the
idea that there are factual tidbits
woven in in this document meaning I
think Oak Shannon had a health problem
who was one of the individuals named uh
and a uh who I consider a friend also
Jay from Project Unity and actually
Tracked Down Oak Shannon and I give him
a lot of credit for that because he
added to the story track this guy down
did an interview and uh although the guy
didn't say look these notes are real he
essentially confirmed the part where he
had a medical issue at the time was very
hard to get a hold of he was the guy
that allegedly Admiral Wilson had
contacted to ask about Eric Davis's
credibility right so this guy comes out
and it kind of confirmed the health
issue and so then the argument began uh
well look if it's a hoax how would all
of these real facts get in there no
one's considering the fact that if it is
a hoax and it was written by someone uh
that had the knowledge and of the
details there that it would be from a
very small select group of people and
and sadly when it comes to these types
of government people a lot of them stay
around each other through history you
know the the Dr Hal put off Eric Davis
all those guys have found themselves in
very tight-knich groups through the
years through different programs and uh
and and research Endeavors and so look
I'm not a I'm not accusing Davis of
writing it I'm not accusing put off uh
but rather it doesn't surprise me that
you're going to have factual elements in
a hoax document so you can't rely on
that you can't say well this guy really
really did have health issues Ergo it's
a real document I'm not saying this but
I could easily come back and say well
you've only supported the fact that he
had health issues maybe he wrote it you
know like I'm not making that claim but
it's a it's a that that rebuttal has
just as much weight as saying that the
documents are confirming the existence
of crashed alien spacecraft so you know
you you do have that debate there so not
to go off on a tangent but but I said
earlier in the interview how you have to
drill in to every single aspect to these
phenomena these cases these photographs
these videos every single thing and
you've got to put it under a microscope
the same is true for a document that's
you know eight nine pages whatever it is
you have to look at every little thing
you have to look at every
fact that you can squeeze out of it
every potential fabrication you can
squeeze out of it who is involved and so
on and go from there and and I just
think at this point you don't have
anything to support these that these
notes were legitimate
um many fall back to the fact that they
were found in Edgar Mitchell's estate I
don't think that that's refuted nor
would I refute it I'm sure that they
probably would be I shook hands with
Edgar Mitchell many times I met him
through the years lectured at the same
conferences uh there was a very young me
picture in my early lecture days in him
next to a stage uh so so I met him
and I can tell you he was an amazing
individual and American hero but amazing
individuals and American Heroes can get
duped as well and so whomever gave him
those documents it doesn't automatically
make them gospel that he kept them in
his archive so I think that a lot of the
arguments that are going to say look
they were in Edgar Mitchell's estate
well that doesn't really matter this
tidbit was real well that doesn't really
matter we need to get actual verifiable
proof If you're going to say these notes
confirm alien crashed spacecraft and
that there are secret programs
investigating that in the private sector
that deny even a J2 access to it you got
to do a little bit more than that in my
book
so the counter is hey you're saying that
someone made a hoax gave it to Edgar
Mitchell put in some fact about auction
and sickness that you would have to
uncover decades later by interviewing
sources by interviewing people
likely is that is that the counter No in
fact uh for me the counter and and I'm
not saying it's a script and and this
really upsets a lot of people out there
but I did a video in the video breakdown
I did I used a script as as a potential
alternate explanation that if somebody
was creating a fictionalized scene of
something that was happening
um this was a way to do it you have real
people you have uh real events you pull
in real facts uh when you read it it's
it I mean it's even using uh like a a
bunch of exclamation points the uh
interrupted and there's like scene cues
what we would call scene cues now I
wrote scripts for quite a long time for
yeah I noticed that as well when I read
that I found that odd and I hadn't seen
that in any other document but I haven't
read several other documents like
yourself well there's and In fairness
there's not many that allege the same
thing or have the same type of backstory
so it's kind of a a standalone a
standalone issue here where you you kind
of have to start from scratch and
evaluate this thing but yeah the way
that it was written was was a little bit
unique now if if somebody wants to put a
pile of Eric Davis notes in front of me
and that's how he writes uh cool we can
have that conversation uh but for me I I
used a hypothetical alternative that in
my opinion had just as much evidence to
support it I pulled a script I just
happened it's in my my shelves behind
that curtain back there but I have a
script from around the same era of
um essentially scene setups the same way
the dialogue the same very similar way
you dissect what was popular at the time
it were paranormal themed uh television
shows uh you look at I think Jonathan
Frakes was hosting one The X-Files was
popular so on and so forth so I was
using that as kind of like this
potential alternative
that in my book had just as much
supporting circumstantial barely any
evidence to support it but why not
consider that if you're truly unbiased
you'll consider both I can consider that
it's real absolutely somebody shows it
to me tomorrow you can error this to
your to your uh audience I would believe
it if I have enough proof I will change
my mind that's not a problem what
interests me are the people that will
come down on you will never change your
mind won't even consider it and to this
day I get people that have their
sarcastic oh it's like Greenwald
thinking it's a script again or
something like that well I stand by it I
mean it had all the Hallmarks of being a
fictionalized creative account of an
event
and I even went into I mean you can
start filling in the blanks but Davis
had recently lost his job around that
time with Robert Bigelow
um yeah you want to go on a stretch hey
what if this was concocted for him to
save his job like hey look this is these
are the types of meetings that I've had
and it got out of hand copies were made
passed around Edgar Mitchell gets a copy
he was connected uh to that group as
well again that's a hypothetical I'm not
placing the accusation but rather all of
these are plausible scenarios
and the argument to tell me that there's
a secret government program that can
authenticate crashed alien spacecraft
that's great
but you can't tell me that these notes
prove that right it could be eighty
percent verifiable facts but that does
not tell me that crashed alien
spacecraft is here uh or are here and
the government has them and and is
hiding it from you we've we've got to do
better than that
um so can Congress I I guess pull it
pull those guys under oath and see what
happens but when when people
and I hate to speak in generality I just
hate to like say this person or that
person so again these are this is part
of the more bigger conversation you see
this a lot in in various articles uh
even published in mainstream articles
where uh if
if Wilson says no and denies it he's a
liar
he has a security oath he has to do that
uh if a military officer decorated comes
out and says something that they want to
believe however they saw a UFO it was a
tic-tac-shaped object that was uh going
speeds that they had never seen before
that's automatically gospel because
they're the military that the the the
how dare you go against the military and
deny what they say and that to me is
such the hypocritical mindset of of some
of these debates that if a military
person says something and you label them
a liar what's the difference between
that and somebody coming out from the
military and telling you something you
want to believe and yes a lot of those
authors will do that hypocritical stance
and that's what's frustrating we we
can't just rely on military background
as a carte blanche acceptance of
whatever they say uh in the same respect
we can't just well they have a security
clearance we we have to believe that
they're lying
um or the note said he would lie so Ergo
he's lying those are all silly Minds
sets to be in I mean if we are going to
start saying that pieces of paper prove
alien spacecraft are there and the
government has them we have to do better
than that and that's why at the end of
the day the Wilson Davis documents sure
I'm open to them being real I mentioned
Jay from Project Unity digging out Oak
Shannon and putting him onto his YouTube
channel interviewing him I gave him a
lot of credit I watched it I was not
convinced of anything more or less than
I was before I watched it but I give him
a lot of credit for doing that and
that's what we need to do
what is the Baghdad Phantom
so Baghdad Phantom was one of the videos
Jeremy Corbell has leaked out I am not a
fan of leaks anybody who follows The
Black Vault I like to get things
legitimately I'm not a fan of leaks
mostly because 99 of the time they don't
pan out what has intrigued me about
Jeremy is that his leaks have panned out
his videos do get comments that I've
received from the Pentagon will get a
comment for the most part of them being
utilized by the UAP task force the
Baghdad Phantom was a little bit
different but I pay attention to Jeremy
Corbell I don't agree with his stance on
everything but pay attention to him
because he obviously has connections
he's obviously bringing stuff out
the Baghdad Phantom was one that was
recent I was surprised it didn't get
more media attention it really didn't
get a lot at all and is a what we think
what we're told a UAP an unknown object
streaking across a video I think this
particular one was taken by an MQ-9
Reaper drone we keep hearing about the
mq-9s a lot and was over a war zone
so
that being said with it being a leak we
don't have more than that we're told
it's a UAP but we don't have more than
that at the recent UAP hearing something
interesting happened where Another War
Zone footage video was shown uh where it
had a ghost-like image trailing behind
it it's the only best way to explain it
and I had noted that from the Baghdad
Phantom but some people thought it was
an exhaust and what I did was posted on
Twitter and I can send this to you is
that when you look at the object which
was a make sure I get through and camera
angle right more of a cylindrical object
you had essentially the exact same
length images behind it in repeat it's
like a ghost image pardon the pun with
Phantom but it was like a ghost image of
the image not an exhaust plume and and
oddly that came up in the UAP hearing
that they were talking about that being
an artifact on the video so that again
not the Baghdad Phantom but something
very similar was having these ghost-like
images trailing behind whatever the UFO
was in the case of the hearing they
claimed it was a commercial aircraft uh
that that particular one they were able
to solve they showed one other one that
also oddly resembled a Jeremy Corbell
leak uh that was the mosul orb I think
is what Jeremy called it not the same
video but similar object so did the
Pentagon plan that or is it just a
commonality between all their cases that
they're primarily seeing these long
cylindrical type objects on the uh
either FLIR cameras or whatever or these
spheres like the mosul sphere flying
across at the UAP hearing they said that
this video was unidentified so yet again
a connection to Jeremy corbell's leaks
uh what they are not really sure because
with leaks it's hard to verify buy
anything beyond what we're told we don't
know who the source is we don't know
where it exactly came from we don't know
what the government considers it not
that the government couldn't or wouldn't
lie to you but in essence there's
nothing to to go by so it's a little
challenging to figure it out I did file
foia requests though to
dig in a little bit deeper I do have
reason to believe that there are more
objects from the same time frame in the
same region so I have filed foia
requests on that as well we'll see if
they come up but uh interestingly I
think the the one that the government
showed was uh within the same 60-day
Mark in the Middle East that uh
something was going on over there I
don't know what it was but it just seems
like during that time frame there was
quite a bit so we'll we'll see how they
pan out what about the Ukrainian uaps
I didn't research that a lot you're
talking about the paper that was
published and look with the war zone and
stuff going through the sky by the
thousands when it comes to weaponry
um I
I will be the first to admit I'm not a
scientist so a lot of times when you
start getting into science math and uh
calculations and stuff like that it's
going to be over my head I'm fully fully
aware of my limitations when it comes to
that so I didn't dig in in that regard
but to me it you know I I don't think it
was as impressive as uh some of the
media made it out to be or some of the
people wanted it to be in the general uh
convert UAP conversation you're talking
about a war zone you're talking about
something that there's going to be so
much in the sky so for that one you're
saying there's too much noise it could
be may not be let's move on we have
others that are exactly